les livraisons de l'étude PISA sont
rarement agréables à la France et ce
mésime 2023 ne déroge malheureusement
pas à ce constat dans un contexte
général de baisse globale de la
performance des systèmes éducatifs de
l'OCDE baisse de 15 points en
mathématique et de 10 points en
compréhension et de l'écrit baisse
encore plus marqué en France avec une
proportion d'élèves peu performants qui
progressent tandis que celle d'élèves
très performants régressent l'état de
notre école les savoirs de nos enfants
inquièteent les Françaises et les
Français monsieur le ministre et parti à
cette désagréable impression de
déclassement dont il nous parle en face
notre groupe se félicite des annonces
que vous venez de faire pour établir
l'autorité des professeurs offrir de
meilleures conditions d'apprentissage se
concentrer sur les savoirs fondamentaux
refondre des programmes annonce qui
complète celle déjà faite sur la lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire et les
carrières des enseignants avec lucidité
nous avons des obstacles à franchir pour
gagner ce choc des savoirs que vous
souhaitez initier certains de ces
obstacles sont sociétaux la place des
écrans la confiance dans dans l'avenir
la transmission parentale d'autres sont
organisationnel un professeur face à
chaque enfant les bonnes méthodes les
bons manuels et les troisèmes tiennent
de principes le respect du professeur la
valeur du diplôme le passage du concret
à l'abstrait monsieur le ministre
sommes-nous condamnés à observer cette l
de chutee à chaque livraison PISA et
comment pouvons-nous principalement au
collège à inverser la donne comment
assurer aux françaises et aux Français
que nous serons désormais en mesure de
regagner notre
rang merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel Atal ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la présidente Isabelle roche parmi tous
les points que vous avez évoqué je veux
m'arrêter sur la question des
mathématiques parce qu'une grande nation
c'est une nation mathématique et qu'on
peut pas se satisfaire de la chute
massive du niveau en mathématique encore
constaté à l'occasion des résultats de
PISA très concrètement j'ai annoncé un
certain nombre de mesures pour relever
le niveau des élèves français en
mathématiques ça commence à l'école
primaire avec des manuels en
mathématiques labelllisé avec les
enseignements de la science et de la
pratique et dont seront doté toutes les
écoles primaires pour au moins CP et CE1
prière chose deuxè chose les groupes de
niveau au collège pour enfin réussir à
faire progresser tous les élèves alors
même que la trop grande hétérogénéité
dans les classes aujourd'hui conduit
certains à stagner et empêche les autres
de s'envoler nous aurons des groupes de
niveau en mathématiqu enfin au lycée
avec Carole grandjan nous allons
renforcer le volume aaire en terminal
professionnel des mathématiques
dispenser les enseignements de
mathématique et de français en petit
groupe pour la seconde et la première
professionnelle et enfin j'assume le
souhait que la France adopte désormais
la méthode de Singapour pour
l'enseignement des mathématiques cette
méthode qui a fait ses preuves dans 70
pays autour de nous qui a été construite
en s'inspirant également des racines
françaises et de Ferdinand Buisson qui
lui-même affirmait qu'il faut commencer
par le concret avant l'imager puis
l'abstrait nous allons progressivement
l'adopter en commençant dès septembre
prochain pour CP CE1 et nous allons
désormais créer une nouvelle épreuve
anticipée de mathématiques en fin de
première pour tous les élèves nous avons
aujourd'hui une épreuve anticipée de
français pour tous les élèves en fin de
première car nous considérons à juste
titre que la maîtrise du français est
fondamament
dans Lele de culture commune de nos
élèves je l'affirme notre culture
commune elle est aussi scientifique et
donc désormais l'ensemble des élèves en
fin de première auront une épreuve
anticipée de mathématique pour réhausser
notre niveau d'exigence JECI monsieur le
ministre madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre pour ces annonces
et pour ce programme ambieux et notre
groupe sera à vos côté pour soutenir
cette politique merci merci beaucoup